On February 24,
my daughter spoke for the first time.
First word was “ba-bah,”
which means the sound
of a great explosion.
That night, we woke
to the concussive sound of bombs
as our windows came crashing in.
It was the bombardment of Kyiv.
I'm someone who didn't believe
it would happen.
I was born just a few days
before the Chernobyl disaster
and a few years before the collapse
of the Soviet Union.
I grew up in an independent Ukraine,
struggling to overcome the legacy
of the Soviet system.
My mother and my grandmother
worked very hard
so that I could have a good education
because they believed
my generation would build the country.
And we have.
Until six weeks ago,
Ukraine was on an upward path,
becoming more prosperous,
more fair, more free.
In 2004 and 2013,
we marched for democracy,
and we defeated autocracy.
So I was stunned
when the windows crushed in.
I froze.
Speechless, motionless,
absolutely helpless.
That was my first lesson of war.
What you cherish can be taken
from you in a moment.
Even your peace of mind.
My hands were still shaking as I fled
to the west of Ukraine with my children
and then over the border to Slovakia.
My husband and my parents remain
in Kyiv, helping our country.
As we traveled further from our family,
I imagined all that was being destroyed.
Our homes, our hospitals,
our critical infrastructure
and so much more.
For 40 million people in my country
and for billions around the globe,
February 24 is the day
Russia invaded Ukraine.
For seven million Ukrainian children,
it is also the day
Russia tried to take their future.
176 children have been killed
by Russian bombs.
Hundreds more have been wounded.
Ten years ago,
I dedicated myself
to building world-class schools
for the children of Ukraine.
I believe education
is the most powerful tool
for improving the economy,
the environment and human well-being.
War very quickly destroys all three.
So far, 900 schools
have been critically damaged.
84 are completely destroyed.
And yet, education goes on.
During the COVID pandemic,
Ukrainian government engaged my team
to create the Ukrainian school online.
During the last two years,
it has delivered school to children
wherever they were.
Students from remote areas
had access to teachers and lessons
they wouldn't have otherwise.
This platform covers the secondary
school curriculum
and puts every student in front
of our very best teachers.
We never imagined our nonprofit
project would be needed in a situation
even more horrible than COVID.
But today, almost 400,000 students
learn on this platform.
They connect from within Ukraine
and from 120 countries
where they are refugees at the moment.
And for all of them,
those couple of hours a day
is not just a safe environment
where they learn something new.
It is also the space where,
despite everything,
Ukraine continues to invest in them.
And that was my second lesson of war.
Putin can take a lot from us.
Our homes, our jobs,
our loved ones, our peace.
But he cannot undo education.
Knowledge and curiosity
are unassailable treasures.
And as long as our children keep learning
and our teachers keep teaching,
even while they are starving
in shelters under bombardment,
even in refugee camps,
we are undefeated.
In this war, every Ukrainian
has his own front.
Our soldiers, our doctors, our mothers.
And, yes, even our children and teachers.
By continuing to learn,
they fight for our future.
And this fight is about
so much more than borders.
Ukrainians are fighting for freedom,
for our right to imagine and build
our future in our own way.
Our people stand heroically.
But against the second-largest
army in the world,
we cannot stand alone.
To end this war, we need you.
We need every citizen in every nation
to demand that it stops.
And that was my third lesson.
My freedom is connected to yours.
My daughter's first word
was the sound of destruction.
But as she grows,
I know she and the rest of her generation
will build Ukraine again.
We will rehabilitate our roads,
our schools, our hospitals,
our houses and people.
Fueled by knowledge and curiosity,
we will walk again the path
to become a prosperous, free nation.
If you stand with us.
So please,
don't watch from the side.
Don't wait and see.
Stand up with us now.
Stand up for freedom.
Stand up for democracy.
Stand up for Ukraine.
Thank you.
(Applause)